[Music]
oh it's so nice to be back I love this
show it's a wonderful cast it's like
being home surrounded by the best of the
best oh yeah no I'm sick of everybody
but not as sick as they are of me
I feel so grateful that we get to do
another season of this show it's just
been the best season iron and Poppy have
broken out on their own they're building
their own game Ian's working on Poppy's
game instead of the other way around
most of the season is spent exploring
how their partnership withstands that
new Dynamic can't work like this I can't
work like this it's clear that we all
can't work like this work like what at
bathcoat Mythic Quest David is doing his
best to keep things under control with
finally a helpful assistant in Joe
celebrate this man Don't Force It David
has taken over Mythic West which is on
time and on budget you have a meeting in
five minutes boss
I sure do
Brad has just gotten out of prison I was
like how are we gonna get out am I going
to come out with neck tattoos like
what's the deal here he's our new
janitor I'm excited to get cleaning
okay I'm really excited for people to
see Poppy and ions Grim Pop I think it's
like a really great new space it sort of
has this futuristic and minimalistic
feel to it office
cyan
yeah that's nice that's nice that is
nice I'm really excited for everyone to
get to see these characters outside of
the original appearance that we've
gotten to know them as you know what
this
it's weird I think a lot of people
thought that maybe the end of season two
was like wrapping things up but wow
there's so many more Adventures that we
have to do if you already love mq you're
going to get the same LOLs okay if
you're new to mq you're getting some fun
funky fresh characters that you didn't
even know you needed in your life
you're welcome
[Applause]
rejoice
[Applause]